we advise all those over 70 with serious
medical conditions against going on
cruises and we advise against
international school trips at some point
in the next few weeks we are likely to
go further and if someone in a household
has those symptoms we will be asking
everyone in that household to stay at
home we're not introducing this measure
yet for reasons sir Patrick will explain
but I want a signal now that this is
coming down the track we are considering
the question of banning major public
events such as sporting fixtures and the
scientific advices we've said over the
last couple of weeks is that this
banning such events will have little
effect on the spread but there is also
the issue of the burden that such events
can place on public services so we're
discussing these issues with colleagues
in all parts of the United Kingdom and
we'll have more to say shortly about the
timing of further action in that respect
all stages we have been guided by the
science and we will do the right thing
at the right time
we are not repeat not closing schools
now the scientific advice is that this
could do more harm than good at this
time but of course we're keeping this
under review and this again may change
as the disease spreads schools should
only closed if they are specifically
advised to do so and that remains our
advice there is no escaping the reality
that these measures will cause severe
disruption across our country for many
months the best scientific advice is
that this will help us slow the disease
and save lives there will be detailed
information available on the NHS website
and
from one-one-one online but I want to
stress something that's very important
in the wake of what we're saying this
afternoon I urge people who think in
view of what we're saying about their
potential symptoms that they should stay
at home I urge them not to call one one
one but to use the internet for
information if they can I also want at
this stage to speak directly to older
people because this disease is
particularly dangerous for you for older
people even though the vast majority of
older people will experience a mild to
moderate illness I know that many people
will be very worried and I think we
should all be thinking about our elderly
relatives there are more vulnerable
members of our family our neighbors and
everything we can do to protect them
over the next few months we're going to
need to mobilize millions of people to
help and support each other and I just
want you to know that the government
will do all we can to help you and your
family during this period we're not just
going to be as you saw yesterday
supporting the economy during this
period we will be providing money and
many other forms of support and helping
communities to support each other and as
we've done over the last few weeks we
will continue to provide as soon as we
have it as much clear scientific and
medical information as we can so I'd
like to end by repeating the two
important messages with which you will
become familiar it is still vital that's
more vital than ever that we remember to
wash our hands and lastly of course even
if things seem tough now just to
remember that we will get through this
this country will get through
this epidemic just as it has got through
many tougher experiences before if we
look out for each other and commit
wholeheartedly to a full national effort
and I'd now like to thank I'd like to
ask Sir Patrick valence in watching the
UK Prime Minister Boris Johnson with the
latest in their phased approach to this
coronavirus saying that this is the
delay phase is now being implemented and
the main measure is that from tomorrow
if people in the UK have Korean virus
symptoms they are in other words a cough
and a fever they are to stay at home for
at least seven days at this stage the
government is not considering closing
schools and he said the most dangerous
period with the Korean virus is some
weeks away depending on the spread neve
barker is here listening to that so kind
of as predicted that they're
implementing this in in phases and and
it's just one notch up from what we had
before yes Boris Johnson clarified it
was that it's about doing the right
thing at the right time and the belief
right now is that the UK doesn't need to
do what other countries in Europe have
done by banning large gatherings or or
telling schools and universities and and
nurseries to close the belief here is
that the scientific evidence says that
those measures right now are not going
to to help nevertheless the government
has said that the containment stage has
now passed the focus now should be on
delaying the spread of the virus until
at least the summer months whether the
country's national health service will
be better poised to deal with possibly
more people needing support but clearly
an attempt also to address the fear
element because he said he did accept
the many more families you said are
going to lose loved ones before their
time so there will be people who who
will die from coronavirus in the end
particularly the emphasis is is kind of
reassuring older people wasn't it yeah
he spoke directly to to older people
whenever we hear about the impact of the
corona virus we hear therefore a large
majority of people it will be the
symptoms will be quite light that that
most certainly we're not talking about
being hospitalized but there is of
course a huge section or at least the
British population that are worried
about the potential impact people with
underlying health issues people that may
have
existing respiratory disorders that may
well find themselves being profoundly
affected by this virus so yeah an
important moment for Boris Johnson to
speak directly to them and Nev just to
broaden it out to the rest of Europe
quite different measures and people that
countries are at different stages and
doing different things only yeah that's
absolutely right and given the
comparison to what Boris Johnson has
said and what other countries are doing
perhaps there will be some concern and
consternation here that more needs to be
done will we look back at this time and
say that the UK could and should have
implemented bans on public gatherings or
the closures of schools we've seen those
Mesut measures introduced in multiple
countries only earlier today Denmark
Norway Lithuania Ireland Poland and the
Czech Republic have introduced those
measures and clearly closing schools is
not a decision to be taken lightly
because obviously parents will need to
stay home to look after their children
that's gonna have a domino effect on
workplaces and the wider economy so an
important move that these countries are
taking but one that the UK right now
doesn't believe it needs to take you
Baca thank you very much indeed